si sentite scrivete nella chat
adesso ciao ciao e si vede tesi sentite
ciao
ok giochiamo essersi dovremmo esser sì
perché non inizia come non inizia scrive
tesi se ci vedete scriventi ciao ciao o
dovrò mostre dovremmo esserci differenza
dovrebbe essere tutto ok ok si iniziano
a vedere tutti i vostri messaggi
piaciuto attività sportive grazie per
gli auguri allora scrivete ste c sentite
bene si sentite bene
scriveteci ci vedete bene scrive tc
visto leggenda
grazie grazie grazie per gli auguri ti
vediamo benissimo male e mi sentite ci
sentite bene augurio di marchisio
grazie no sì sì sì sì sì sono arrivati
tutti in 3d o che ci siamo allora
innanzitutto grazie mille oggi è il mio
compleanno grazie mille altre tele
persone che mi hanno fatto gli auguri
sias ho fatto prima di tutto un fatto un
post su instagram però già da ieri notte
dopo un messaggio quello di voi mi hanno
scritto un rigo brevi messaggi privati
di instagram facendogli gli auguri
grazie davvero siete troppo carini
veramente non so come avete fatto a
ricordarvene dall'anno scorso perchè
avevamo fatto una diretta anche l'anno
smorto e poi ho fatto il posta anche
nella community di youtube è un sacco di
voi mi hanno fatto busta con tacchi di
auguri grazie grazie grazie mille
abbiamo deciso di fare questa live in
cui posteremo pulite un postivi auguri e
chiacchiere a un pochettino è poi
giochiamo assieme ad amgas perché ci
chiedete sempre di giocare a pieve in
diretta da o gas da quando abbiamo fatto
da dire
viene risolto e appetito attenzione il
codice lo vedrete direttamente sullo
schermo questa volta non sarà sulle ita
g doris e se non mi sei video dato
seguirmi steinhauer però sarà qua in più
ogni volta creare una nuova partita così
non succede come l'altra volta che
sempre il suo io persone rimane del
gioco perché non vogliono andarsene così
mentre la possibilità poi però altre
persone di giocare mi dispiaceva perché
in tanti mi scrive levate anch'io voglio
giocare mi vorreste entrare quindi
faremo una nuova partita però vi avviso
vi avviso già se non avete aggiornato il
gioco sarà aggiornato lo sei
forse perché vogliamo giocare appunto
nella nuova mappa airship se non l'avete
visto andate poi a vedere gli altri
nostri video che ho fatto due tre v3
video in cui giochiamo nella nuova mappa
in cui l'ultimo video si è rotta il
gioco se non avete visto dove vederlo
anzi se volete farvi un regalo di
compleanno
dopo questa diretta andate a vedere i
miei ultimi video e lasciate un mi piace
se volete farmi sapere che arrivate
negli ultimi video dalla diretta che io
c'ero marciarono la diretta poi vado vi
leggo e la sicuri cini comunque andare
adesso leggo un po dimostri come l'ho
trovato un adoratore domande con quanti
imposta rigiocheremo mentre perché se
colore divertente anche se nella nuova
mappa è un caso perché la grande e poi
non si capisce bene dove andare
tante norme però dai problemi con tre
magari siete un pubblico non aiutiamo
due allora grazie perché no un sacco di
muri grazie cari grazie berlino sta
dormendo
speriamo che non si svegli se noi
abbiamo fatto stancare un pochino ha
giocato male abbiamo giocato fuori in
giardino e adesso sta riposando per esse
si sveglia lui ogni volta che ci veda
che facciamo i video sul tavolo viene e
vuole sedersi nella sedia al posto di
vitale e berlino youtube e credibile per
viva è uno youtubers veramente è infatti
in alcuni video e ve ne siete accorti
inizia con berlino il posto di vita
perché lui gli ha rubato il fossero
praticamente
così non viene rubare il posto capitale
allora mi state scrivendo ma lasciatela
live dopo certo dopo la pubblichiamo
se volete potete riguardarla potete
rivedere i momenti più divertenti
quello che volete e lasciatemi cazzo su
questa mi raccomando lasciatemi viaggi
facciamo la scorsa volta non mi ricordo
quanti mi piace comunque abbiamo
superato i 10mila vi piace alla scorta
live
quindi facciamo che anche se se anche
questa live supera i 10mila vi piace ci
sarà un altro alive
però magari consigliateci voi in giochi
da provare magari non amgas ma
qualcos'altro potreste trovare qualche
altro gioco e non serve un pesante solo
voi magari qualche gioco in cui possiamo
sempre a giocare assieme a voi così
ancora più divertente
vi amo posso giocare con te 200 le hanno
come si chiama nuova mappa si chiama
airship ed è una sorta di aereo gigante
c'è la cucina addirittura non so bene
uno spazio dove prima era fatto allora
mi stanno chiedendo aspetta dicono no
potrebbe tornare forma ciao che dai vi
lasciamo spazio per tempo per aggiornare
8 quando siete pronti dite se lo
iniziamo la prima partita adesso vivono
tutto sono fatto solo promette un
commento non mi ricordo più ti voglio
bene
sì certo vi lascio qui piante gran parte
mi raccomando sempre mi piazzo ai server
chiedono ed è ora un po europa europa
quindi segnatevi europa potete fare un
game room
sì perché no che tema vorresti 20 sono
pronto ho aggiornato alla grande che
estate tutti aggiornando che stanno
arrivando tante altre persone io sto
aggiornando aspetta un pochino ti voglio
bene grazie ai migliori live sono shot
[Musica]
gravità vi vediamo ci sentiamo bene
grazie grazie grazie grazie siete troppo
troppo troppo teneri in questi giorni
stiamo leggendo i vostri commenti
privilegiamo sempre i vostri commenti mi
ricordo stavo pensando una cosa horror
dicono di attenzione cazzo si riferisca
alla scrittura
perché noi adoriamo le coste paurose le
adoriamo ormai lo sapete da il video che
che facciamo ma ci piacciono tiene cose
divertenti che l'eco delle cose però le
cose paurose non lo so le adoro io fra
tutte le adoro troppo perché da quando
ero piccola che leggo storie poco o dei
libri paura di più le storie divertenti
[Musica]
non so come aggiornare allora devi devi
difendere android o se hai un
dispositivo android o cellulare sio e
l'iphone o un android quindi per
l'iphone e al west e devi andare
profilo anche nell'app store
sì anche nell'app store direttore piero
chi direttamente among us puoi cliccare
su aggiorna invece per android google
player google princier che clicchi
aggiorna fateci sapere se riuscite
aggiornare quando è il compleanno di
vitale di 67 ha detto io aspettavo di
indovinassero a dominare quindi sia
passato però tra poco ma si tanto in
questo periodo è veramente c'è ma io non
ci credo che siamo già ad aprile
veramente sembra ieri che è iniziato il
2021 e siamo già ad aprile di terzisti
anche per voi così strano il tempo in
questo periodo c'è
non lo so vabbè visto il periodo che
stiamo vivendo sembrano tutte uguali le
giornate sembra che il tempo passa non
basta non si capisce il compleanno di
berlino il complesso davvero difesa 2
gennaio e quest'anno ha fatto due anni e
nell'ultimo viti o quello della fota in
tantissimi se avete scritto che ero
diventato grandi gijon e fatti non
capivo perché come in tanti ci hanno
scritto proprio in quel video
forse per com'era straiato sembra un po
più grande
oppure noi abbiamo pensato che lui in
realtà lui crepe sempre noi non sente
percorso lo vediamo tutti i giorni
l'aveva stati giorni la pensa che sia
cresciuta qui
infanzia tantissimo mangia tanto lenta
tanto sempre in forma programma
veramente tantissimo da chi ha preso
allora siete simpatici ti voglio bene
grandi grazie grazie grazie di grande
allora direi che è passato già un
pochino di tempo con la prima partita
tenetevi pronti perché una volta che
iniziano la partita dovete prendere il
codice che ti appare nella partita e
metterlo
nella stanza di mong asta server europa
ok pronti
ho sempre paura di dimenticarmi qualcosa
che vi devo dire no lo penso che ci sia
tutto allora adesso ci stiamo per farvi
vedere anche lo schermo più faremo
parire il mantello dell'invisibilità di
harry potter alle nostre spalle troppo
come possiamo vedere la magia
allora penso che l'aveva vissuto ok
aspetta ora siamo ci vedete di nuovo
vediamo attiva ci vedete ci sentite
ancora no forse adesso
aspetto sta tornando dai sbrigatevi a
eccoci qua stiamo ricomparsi ci vedete
adesso stiamo dentro mondo allora oggi
ciao vitale 6 spettacoli o addirittura
allora non vi preoccupate però poco si
trova per un momento non ci siamo visti
ma adesso dovremmo dovremmo essere
fateci sapere dalle colibrì hanno
scritto rative rocco crimi pronti perché
dobbiamo grazie nota allora e allora
creiamo la partita abbiamo detto è la
forma lanciato si può mettere italiano
no purtroppo da questo personale al suo
nome perché mi corretti in tanti se
avete scritto un signor m italiano ma
non a pagamento non ci sa fare pratica
stiamo creando scriviamo ecco quindi ma
codice con il codice wv wbf
lo vedete il codice ok vi stiamo
aspettando
guardate io nel personaggio il cappello
del compleanno ti amo unica grazie ai 7
nodi del softball hayden si sente
l'audio alziamo un attimino allora un
attimino gol siamo subito
ok è arrivato a berlino
se è troppo alto l'audio del gioco dito
al cielo berlina arrivato ma sta andando
torna un altro lettino posto ovviamente
voi non votateci come i posti vacanti
allora iniziamo con le tasche tra
l'altro un bivacco di doc non le abbiamo
grow scoperta che bello provare un età
quando g nation la cugina
non è così
ogni minatore preferita di vitale
[Musica]
laminazione adesso siamo puliti e allora
andiamo al bar hamburger in cucina
adesso tanti piatti
no aspetta aspetta senza sbagliato e ci
ha eliminato hanno già vitro partita una
nuova così entrano altre persone
tenetevi pronte pronti per il nuovo si
fa davvero scioccata dunque verde e
liberato subito l'area nuovo codice
f a k htf vi aspettiamo
siamo qui siamo figli come vi do un
consiglio non c'è la micro sim pastori
cecina tutte le persone in diretta tra
cui anche quelli che stanno giocando nel
gioco vedranno chi è l'imputato
eccoli qua si parla ai andiamo verde
vista vogliamo andare a fare un burger
vediamo un po iniziare
partiamo dalla cucina questa volta
allora in questo momento non ci abbia un
significato in cucina questa volta però
vediamo gli altri o guarda bisogna
pulire il rubino un vino che insieme
alla tasca nuovo che non vediamo stanza
è bellissima praticamente se avete visto
l'altro video di amore justin cui
reagiamo a tutte le stanze della mappa
biamonti da parte dei vari capi non
avete visto andate a vederlo dopo quella
stanza lì quando arrivò in quella stanza
io ero tipo emozionate trattata c'è un
diamante da pietra a ruota dai diamanti
sono bianchi e quindi è un rubino non è
un diamante di parsimonia monte andate a
vedermi ofanto skip non se ne frenò ma
cos'è successo io ero distratta qualcuno
sia riportato un corpo
quindi nessuno è stata parliamo scrivete
nella chat che sospetto secondo voi
vediamo collaboriamo tutti assieme anche
se non siete entrati nel gioco
partecipare perché scrivendo nella foto
partecipate alle investigazioni e con
rubino allora voglio vedere cosa farà
vasche completata poi qui che sappiamo
bene jean potete chiudere e riaprire o
no durante la pena
qualcuno che c'è minato noi non possiamo
partecipare siamo stati eliminati
ok berg ottobre viola perché ovviamente
chi vede la live ben si credono vinto
nove degli impostori
allora direi questa volta di diminuire i
pranzi liberi nuovo cosa sia che attenti
ad esso
allora allora vediamo adesso potete
provare a entrare vedere con il
[Musica]
vincitore
siete arrivati due velieri vero di lecce
pronti
spero di non abitare impostori tutti lo
sanno che noi scappato
adesso se in questa partita durerà molto
poco
ovviamente si eliminerà tutti stanno
votando ovviamente avranno un dato noi
[Musica]
[Risate]
non possiamo continuare come bonera e
facciamo i fantasmi comunque sto
scherzando avete fatto bene perché
colori i cru mail possono vincere siamo
potuto sabotare però
ciao e grazie
[Musica]
non mi fa entrare dovete aspettare il
nuovo codice
tra poco tra poco devi mettere pubblica
no pubblica non posso mettere pubblica
perché altrimenti è un personaggio le
persone possono entrare c'è non solo
quelle che hanno il codice ma tutti e
quindi entrerebbero anche persone che
non c'entra niente con la stori spagnoli
con noi con voi che state guardando il
video io voglio apprezzò lo bue fra
entrate tra l'altro una volta è successo
che per sbaglio essere una live mi
sembra un video normale vaticano
tarchiato editing del video compromessa
pretorio pubblica e ma non se n'era uno
sciopero iniziati arrivare questi
commenti in inglese che chiedevano
perché trovo molto ti parlando in
italiano troppo divertente luca
raccogliere dai stomach remake sapete
chi sono le posture potete farcela dai
conto su di voi anche se mi avete
eliminato è contato ieri l'altro il
pastore la migliore augurio
cosa senti commentato alloggi fatto bene
abbiamo addirittura vinto sono usciti
per il ragazzo che sono usciti perché
non è possibile che ha vinto abito solo
risposto è vero perché mettiamo un
impostore articolo inseriamo che non
capì diamo noi che ho fatto a lui è una
partita difficile
portiamo un pochino più avanti un nuovo
dato certo dice vai c xhb f vi
aspettiamo
nel frattempo nel cupo in qualche
commenti così vede ti sento benissimo e
nord america
no europa siamo sicuri dovrebbe essere
europa come dire che abbiamo sbagliato
dove è stato arrestato questa denuncia
fuori però dovrebbe essere dopo quando
pensano al nuovo fratelli contro gli
auguro mai siamo arrivati in avanti vedo
che bianco 6 chiamato in porto lasciando
la tarsu fondere tutti vediamo vediamo
vediamo nessuno del gioco non si sente
però ho sentito il suono del gioco o non
l'ho sentita
allora che morgan abbia
qual è quella più vicina
domani lo rifate no penso che domani
escono un video normali più narrativi
piazza nota anche queste live ma
lasciate un mi piace a 10 mila mi piace
fare un'altra live
buon compleanno
[Musica]
anche se è il mio secondo compleanno in
quarantena sulla rossa purtroppo tra
l'altro anche l'anno scorso ho fatto una
live decorate avevo fatto vedere il
regalo di compleanno che era che cos'era
chissà su chi se lo ricorda passo non
l'avete vista andate poi a vederla mi
dice che non posso entrare perché tra
iniziata europa non funziona dopo
ricontrolliamo forse abbiamo sbagliato
qualcosa allora
seleziona dell'europa noi controlliamo
adesso dirà allora abbiamo due tribiano
elettrica perché è imposto lecce
scrittura in effetti un po severo qui
come faccio mi manca l'ascensore ma mi
aspetta però fa non siamo mai se c'è
qualcosa che un appello porto della
mappa che non abbiamo visto questa morsa
ok è quella con l'ascensore che vadano
partiamo però sarei pronta così si fa da
tarquini che tasche questa questo può
farlo o tre settimane livecast fido non
so se ci riesco non funziona perché è
già iniziata la partita o questa
proposta non ho capito una cosa vera ma
se devi tener premuto
si è attaccato a lui forse devo fare
così come saputo e lo si aiuta
non ho capito che sta succedendo
comunication saputo giusta equa rete la
presa abbiamo aiutato ho capito se rotto
tutto ma sono bloccati
chissà forse qui sopra con la mappa a
leggere i problemi nel frattempo sei la
mia itala mi metti un nome a caso negli
altri video di amon verso che ho fatto
mi avete sentito nei commenti che mi
dispiace che non potete più cambiare
numero il tassisti puo cambiare
però adesso chiede di creare un account
con l'aggiornamento vi dovete creare
l'account c'è qualcuno di strano non lo
so che gli impeti parlamenti che è che
corrono fo strani ma non lo so forse il
solo qua dal computer
comunque vi basta creare l'account e
puoi cliccare su chains mi cambia nome
dentro all'account e potete cambia ma io
non ho capito come funziona questa tasca
mela spiegate per favore dice di farlo
sette volte però non capisco è provava
calzare abbassare o perché me la toglie
quando piaciute perché devi tenere
premuto fino a che non arrivasse sto
tenendo premuto per niente luna
solbiatese può capitare
vabbè proviamo un'altra top si blocca e
tempo
allora vediamo
i consigli vedi il giallo hanno detto
giallo so k sono gli impostori secondo
me penso che forse intendono bianchi ho
capito come funziona questa task
praticamente bisogna andare in giro
[Musica]
allora qua hanno detto che sas giallo
come parcheggio anni chi altro sasso
secondo voi giallo giallo per di loro ha
detto il giallo mentre io schifo sono
sicuro non voglio incolpare giallo
[Musica]
prendere ora spiegato lanciato perché mi
avete proprio perché mi avete perso il
contatto e mi avete fatto uscire
e sapete cosa è un fiume perché tutti
vestirà via dire gianni gianni giallo
invece che nel dei saperi e giallo
[Musica]
io voglio sapere al continuano a
scrivere il giallo è giallo
poverina già vissuto di giallo
tantissimi auguri ai soliti seguito a
tre anni bianco e giallo dicono che sono
imposto marino cioè abbiamo impostato
giallo bianco altro corpo è stato
trovato vota giallo vedi tu cosa hai
fatto prima romito arginano eliminato
questo perché prima non toccatelo li
vota adesso andiamo a vedere giallo così
come siamo fantasmi
seguiamo i sospetti soldi
ci viene invece allora seguiamo giallo e
vediamo se l'hanno già votato
vediamo ora scoprire un nuovo no state
aspettando vince
tanto l'anno scappato seguiamo giallo
vediamo se hanno ragione loro
caspita documentando devo tantissimo non
altro la regione 118
per chi è arrivato dopo non vi
preoccupate perché poi la falco questa
live la pubblico che li potete rivederla
dall'inizio giallo si sarà nascosto in
qualche evento
io sono un impostore dice qualcuno che
dice che colore strano come noi votiamo
nero sta aspettando per entrare immagine
ma se un po ti vai scritto anche che se
una pesca da fare in bagno
volete scoprire come questa allora nera
sta seguendo il giallo
secondo me non il giallo allora non era
né nero nel giallo che non è ma magari
l'ha fatto prima ha eliminato prima del
mostro ma non abbiamo visto niente
chi è stato secondo voi scrivete
scrivete c
[Musica]
ti hanno votato perché mentre giocano
non vedono la suite posto re c'è un
potere
[Musica]
chi sta giocando magari non vede giusto
alive mostro non lo so da in base a
quello che scrivono ci mettiamo allora
avrete notato avrete votato tutti da
allora che io ho detto in continua tra
san paolo perché voi sapete il tutto
comunque i batteri prima che alcuni come
ritoccano guardo una live ma vera coni
d'ombra
fabio si ok pronti come forse un po dice
protti
ecco il codice by dkfz vi aspettiamo
comunque magari alcuni guardano la live
da un altro cellulare o al completo dal
computer che giocano poi nel cellulare
ad among us
anzi vi consiglio di fare così così
potete seguire anche quello che noi
diciamo frattempo secondo me non è per
quello che mi hanno votato ma secondo me
ne hanno votato per stato per me di far
vedere che vi arrabbiate che ricomincia
mobilia ma voi vi siete ambienta di bere
con questa nuova mappa vi piace
scrivetecelo nei commenti
scriveteci quindi votato mi arrabbio io
parto dalla cucina
quella fare in cucina la testa nel bagno
[Musica]
però dobbiamo un sacco di cose che
abbiamo guardando perché ti dare in
faccia per l'europa più veloce no perché
penso che voi dovete selezionarlo forse
[Musica]
non so questo fenomeno bosco nella
triste meli buon compleanno grazie
grazie
c'è un aiuto facciamo chiuso oppure luca
dolci
[Musica]
e la quinta volta che provenzale di
sacchetto pieno che sono un fatto di
persone che provano entrare nello stesso
momento di essere super veloce per
quello che stiamo facendo sempre come
parte di personalità c è possibilità per
entrare
allora se arancione che ci sto seguendo
[Musica]
ok allora
le dosi che facciamo
sas chiude maschio volevo dire io voglio
vedere come queste ormai
[Musica]
avete già finito le tasche allora se
avete chiesto aspetto secondo me basta
solo che state vedendo io sto piangendo
no.dai la prossima
[Musica]
siamo a buon punto forse riusciamo a
vincere oggi è il compleanno di anita
sarà c'è scritto nel titolo anche il
cappellino discarica
20 per cento però ancora un pochettino
di liberare dai hai fame vitalissima
febbre
abbiamo prima maggio vitale e se la
volete vedere ho messo la foto su
instagram della storta nella foto se
anche berlino che ha la lingua vuoi
stiamo parrebbe sterline più brutto di
fiori andate a vedere la foto ballo da
vista aspettiamo hanno trovato nel
frattempo
vediamo forse è stato l'azzurro scrivono
infatti ha preso due voti però siccome
ci sono stati due fischi e già berlino
come sta benissimo grande nel letto cosa
così dare il cellulare
sì
basta
così sofferente
ciao
condividiamo
[Musica]
voglio dire no
no
[Musica]
no quella no
potete vederne ok noi abbiamo finito
tutte le tasche chi seguiamo questo
perde un po
[Musica]
continua
è un po andate a fare le vasche dalla
farò le tasche penso che siamo stati gli
unici a fare le basta pochissimo ma
anche la barra piccolissima lì nel cuore
non si sta neanche l'anno da fare volevo
le camere per l'impianto massimo avere
firmato karim beckham olivo store e
vediamo
[Musica]
bianco
dove si stanno nascondendo gli altri
tutti quanti e quali the va bene da
allora c'è in giro vediamo un po verde
sempre appiccicato a noi perché
tantissimi auguri ratti clark verdi
scure sospetto però cifra che secondo me
è un posto non c'era più gente di milano
sono tutti qua perché dall'altra parte
lo sciatore prendere la parola
non è un po difficile
viola o il impostore che non fa
eliminando nessuno guarda rosso rosso
era lì da solo
[Musica]
perché chi è sospetto secondo voi bardet
scuro dicono perde samp
ma chi esce quando ma siccome sempre
vicino a noi non eliminare un matitone
dicono non può essere verde scuro
protesta con noi e con il giallo è
giallo giallo non l'abbiamo vista blu
ho visto tutti i tuoi video
[Musica]
perche gli impostori dicono ma perde
quale c'è solo per dire mi sa che c'è
adesso rosso verde insomma un po tutti i
colori che sono attraverso loro sospetti
tutti allora si viola cosa specializzato
dal sito nascondendo si può nascondere
anche non per forza
dov'è andato bruno che davvero difficile
capire chi l'impostore questa volta
vediamo cosa dite voi rosso verde viola
se non c'è nessun corpo io sono morta
allora dici di essere trattata seno
variamo dobbiamo seguire qualcuno ma
l'impostore non elimina nessuno opere
concrete dell'italia rosso e lì fermo
anche giacci arancione a questo
purtroppo farà l'ultimo partita
no perché purtroppo ogni volta video
nella e potremmo stare con quei parlare
davvero il tempo vola c'è
41 minuti sembrano portati rostotchi
quindi anche per lui è così da
spettatori come scrivete cielo
allora dico nome per viola rossoblù i
prof sono tanti che dicono roma vado a
chi a parole emergenti di rosso rosso è
sparito vogliamo rosso e qua nessuno
perché ero completato le tosto potremmo
vincere ma che pare un'emergenza meeting
si sa benissimo prova per rondo che
facciamo
va bene per un argentino non ha chiamato
io a perché si stavano tutti seguendo è
stato eliminato prendeva cura ha premuto
il pulsante delle merde il che forse non
rende al proprio che sta non lo fa chi
votiamo allora ascoltiamo loro tipico
cross top rosso stato eliminato
io direi verde scuro verde scuro
[Musica]
poverino vediamo chi è allora non potete
più dire rosso per le offerte viola fluo
dicono vai seguì lo osserviamo lo
seguiamo lo scopriamo subito
e blu navy che sto trovando un
velocissimo il mio bel lo sei tu
[Musica]
esistenti eliminando per un momento ma
ma come me e blu e si liberava andare in
un vento forse magari non conosceva
perché la stava esplorando vediamo se
c'è qualcuno nascosto in bagno ai tubi
file viola forte perché lì a quel pro
sono rimasti con noi e non hanno fatto
niente di sospetto
allora dicono blu o viola arancione
fidatevi di me dicono bianco
[Musica]
super divertenti queste partite dobbiamo
giocare diretta beh allora adesso io
vado a chiamare un'emergenza meeting e
chi voti insomma volta reazione quale
arancione viola allora che si arancione
viola stavano tutti e due qui vuol dire
che non sono loro perché altrimenti si
rimane allora se non è arancione non è
viola bianco pochi mesi che bianco blu
lo abbiamo seguito e non ha fatto niente
di strano anche bianco viola non lo
storia non cederò il viola arancione
stavano insieme qui dice se uno dei due
l'impostore ci vorrebbero le eliminate
io voto bianco blu arancione arancio
attiva di me ho dato una notizia
arriviamo nella chat che succede non ci
credo no facciamo adesso non possiamo
più chiamare le summit in tre a ballare
blu e viola bianco non sia con noi
l'impostore elimina dunque non gli basta
eliminare 12 allora dicono e viola
fidatevi
[Risate]
allora blu dicono blu viola beh sono
rimasto vuoto chi può importare da ieri
finale 1 tanto non possiamo più chiamare
gli emergenti miti allora vediamo chi si
allontana viola e bianco sono con noi e
blues è allontanato
però magari andato fra le tasche
eddai imbustare seguiamo blu
sono
lui stampa
chi rimane l'impostore signor impostare
viola dicono no
e se piace non siamo capisco perché
ricordare non elimina nessuno va be che
siamo tutti appiccicati dai muoviamoci
vogliamo ceduto un costone vari spostare
noi ci mettiamo che non contiamo niente
telecamere capisco ok allora qualcuno si
è allontanato
se qualcuno che non ha finito le tasche
innanzi tutto
tutti qui torno allora io le bianco ci
stanno seguendo qui chi è che non c'è
[Musica]
[Applauso]
noi rimaniamo live però non danno non
vedono il video
posso mettere all'asta batteria
sai dobbiamo per forza figlia questo
perché non devo scoprire tutto perché è
ok erice m materia stesso spegnerla
no devo spendere per notai lo facciamo
cosa prendere dopo che proviamo potrebbe
succedere il disastro cioè che svelò il
dott
speriamo di no però dobbiamo per forza
di questa partita allora perché non è
più con noi
anzi andiamo a cercarlo vediamo
leone bianco appiccicati stimi il tuo
blu
il video poi metodisti speriamo che
funzioni
[Musica]
sentite dovreste sentirci ancora
dovreste sentirci però non ci vedete ma
adesso lo stiamo subito riattivando si
sentite mettetelo in carica e telecamere
carica poi sapendo blu e blu
dov'è finito blu ma allora viola e
bianco potete per favore chiamare un
meeting di emergenza così possiamo
votare blu
raga e blu
ok io purtroppo non posso chiamare
nessun altro meeting
allora vediamo se sale qualcosa bianco
che ho lasciato chiamano il meeting
[Musica]
allora bianco la prima ci vede poco
ritorniamo però anche questa batteria
completamente morta vita levavano in via
la batteria è ammessa la batteria
scarica comunque non ci sembra perdere
votiamo blu io voto blu scriviamo blu
così mutato brutte non è blu abbiamo
perso penso vediamo
[Musica]
ecco perché scappava sempre non ci credo
meno male ce l'abbiamo fatta a finire la
partita
la batteria è dimesso era quello che
stava sotto carica collegate
ma proprio dobbiamo finire la live qua
non so neanche se ma poi ci vedete non
lo sto non so come mi guarda troppo
troppo troppo troppo bella questa
partita sì forse sì ok dovreste vedersi
è stata troppo bello a quest'ultima
partita era tempo sei stato bravissimo
bravissima anche per ora eliminato nel
turno c'è pochissimo bersani dica stop
comunque grazie bianco che chiamato il
meeting all'ultimo pur bravissimo adesso
andate a vedere i primi altri vediamo
gas
io scrivo ultimi video lasciate un bel
mi piace degli ultimi video e se arriva
ci è andata di video grazie a questa
diretta
io c'ero mi raccomando lascio ad un mi
piace i miei ultimi vini a questo video
sarà un bellissimo regalo di compleanno
per me grazie ancora parte gli auguri e
grazie per aver partecipato esperti
tantissimo anzi non appena la pubblico
la riguardare tutte le tutti i passaggi
più divertenti tutte le cose poi voglio
rileggere l'assalto l'eccedere le cose
che mi sono persa noi vi mandiamo un
bacione grazie ancora
ci sentiamo nei commenti ciao ciao
[Musica]